you know Song of Ice and Fire cold hands
is a strange mysterious figure with
connections to the three-eyed crow the
children of the forest the Nights Watch
and the others who is he and what is he
let's have a look in book three Sam and
Gilly are attacked by whites north of
the wall they're saved by a thin gaunt
man who wears black clothes rides a
giant elk and uses a huge group of
ravens to fight White's
kind of like in that Hitchcock movie he
never gives a name that Sam calls him
cold hands for his cold black hands cold
hands take Sam and Gilly South to the
abandoned knight fought on the wall and
we learned that he's been sent by the
three-eyed crow to fetch bran Stark so
in dance cold hands leads bran Hodor
Meera and Jojen to the three-eyed crow
far in the north during this journey
meera gets really suspicious of cold
hands because he never really explains
who he is and what's going on he hides
his face behind a scarf and a hood he's
also dead he doesn't eat or breathe or
seem to sleep his heart doesn't beat
cold hands is a lot like a white the
zombie is controlled by White Walkers
they're both described as dead things
pale with cold black hands they're
unable to cross certain magical wards
they don't seem to feel cold and cold
hands fears fire which we know kills
whites but in other ways coal towns is
very different to a white White's have
bright blue eyes but he has black eyes
White's are slow and clumsy but he's
agile White's don't talk but cold hands
speaks in a rattling voice with
intelligence even hints of emotion white
seems to have lost their humanity but
cold hands still seems to be a person
and while White's work for White Walkers
cold hands serves the three-eyed crow
so the three-eyed crow is actually
Brynden rivers or Bloodraven a Targaryen
bastard explored Commander of the Nights
Watch a dreamer wizard green seer and
125 year old man apparently kept alive
by his connection to the weirwoods and
the magic of the old gods blood Ravens
goals and motivations are shady and
unclear but he mostly seems to hang out
with the children of the forest watch
the world through the eyes of weirwood
trees skin change into ravens manipulate
from afar you know standard psychic tree
man [ __ ] some people think that
bloodraven controls cold hands by skin
changing into him like brand controls
Hodor which might happen sometimes but
surely not all of the time
cold hands does seem to exist as his own
person so what keeps this corpse walking
cold hands seems to be connected to the
old gods like the green seers of the
children of the forest he has power over
animals he keeps a group of Ravens to
scout and fight for him and he can speak
with them understand their quacks and
squawks he rides a giant elk and when it
dies Colton performs a little ritual for
it
murmuring a blessing in some strange
tongue as he slits its throat maybe it's
the magic of the old gods that animates
cold hands we've seen zombies of ice
zombies of fire zombies of stone zombies
of necromantic science why not zombies
of nature of the old gods maybe just as
the others resurrect whites with ice
magic and Thoris resurrects beric with
fire magic blood Raven resurrects cold
hands with nature magic
Colton's is just another kind of zombie
so that may explain what cold hands is
the next question is who Colton sees or
who he was before his regime for
resurrection his identity does seem to
be important because Mira keeps asking
about it and cold hands refuses to show
his face or say his real name so who
could he be
Colton seems to have been a brother of
the Nights Watch he calls Sam brother
and wears black though as mirror points
out anyone can put on a black cloak so
it's not certain that he was with the
watch either way for a while a popular
theory was that Coldhands is Benjen
stark Ned's brother who went beyond the
wall in book 1 and never came back
maybe benjin was killed by White Walkers
and later resurrected by blood Raven as
cold hands it was a pretty good idea but
earlier this year
reddit user honey Byrd checked out the
original manuscript of Dance with
Dragons and found a note from George
Martin saying that Colton's is not
benjin so there goes that idea
other possible watchmen include will and
Waymar black brothers killed in the
prologue of book 1 this is kind of
trickier because we know Waymar and
probably will were turned into whites by
the others so for one of them to be cold
hands blood Raven or someone must have
some
restored their mind after there was
amplified which is not something we've
ever seen happen so it seems unlikely
that Colton's is will or Weimer Colton's
was apparently killed long ago and we're
told this by a 200 year old child of the
forest so cold hands probably died years
and years ago one cool idea is that
Colton's is so Duncan the tall the
protagonist of the dunk and egg novellas
said almost a hundred years before the
main series dunk had a relationship with
blood Raven he meets him at the end of
the mystery night and escorted him to
the wall when Bloodraven joined the
watch
maybe dunk joined the watch himself was
killed beyond the wall and became
Colton's
there's no real evidence for this though
and certain facts don't fit like donk is
really tall and Colton's apparently
isn't donk seems to have died at summer
Hall not beyond the wall and if donk
joined the watch we'd have probably
heard about it so that one probably
isn't true either
another theory takes us much further
back and links cold hands to the
legendary Knights King Lord Commander
from 8,000 years ago who apparently
married another or white this would
explain how cold hands notes about the
Black Gate the night's king ruled at the
night fort and may have used the Black
Gate for secret sacrifices but there are
a few reasons where this theory doesn't
fit either firstly the night's king was
apparently cast down by the wildlings
and the Starks but cold hands was
apparently killed by the others even if
the wildlings and stalks let the night's
king live which would be weird because
they apparently obliterated his very
name from memory why would the others
kill the night's king he'd apparently
been making sacrifices to them and even
if they did that doesn't explain why the
night's king would survive as a sentient
Wight for 8,000 years or why he'd end up
working for Bloodraven or why he'd have
power over animals or anything really
and a thousand years is a long-ass time
could a body and mind survive that long
we are told that cold preserves but if
cold hands is so ancient it seems weird
that he's never described as such from
the way he speaks and moves and fights
he seems pretty bloody sprightly for an
eight thousand year old corpse George
Martin has implied that the night's king
has not survived to the present day so
overall it seems unlikely that cold
hands is the night's king one more
theory is that cold hands is a
descendant of the night's king and his
blue-eyed bride human other hybrids
been hinted to exist but cold hands
doesn't really seem like he's part other
others are strange beautiful creatures a
different sort of life but cold hands is
just a dead man
he hasn't got blue eyes or an icy sword
or really any special features of the
White Walkers even if he is some hybrid
that doesn't really explain why his mind
survives his death
besides the night's king's bride seems
more like a white than another and can
you imagine a zombie giving birth to
cold hands would you want to there's all
sorts of spooky magic you could
speculate but at the end of the day
there's just no strong evidence for
their stuff so there are lots of really
interesting possibilities here but none
of them are all that convincing it's
tempting to conclude the cold hands
isn't anyone special at all just some
random nights Watchmen it was killed by
the others then resurrected by
bloodraven but if that's the case why
does cold hands hide his face why do the
books keep drawing our attention to the
mystery of his identity it really seems
like there's something going on here but
for now we simply don't have the answers
we don't know who called Hans's but we
can make a pretty good guess at what he
is he may be a night's watchman who was
killed by the others then was reanimated
with the magic of the old gods
probably by blood Raven and the children
of the forest whoever and whatever he is
cold hands is a really cool character so
hopefully we'll see more of him when
winds of winter finally comes thanks for
watching this video was made with
support of patrons on patreon including
Vanya dog Susan Cooper Trotsky Bobeck
Sharif E&C regalo de tawdry Sanchez
miggles Ruth Sam spend love Daniel
Abdullah Aidan Kenny Mike C has a Fran's
Punk'd and Gregory wolf the second for
updates early access and other books you
can support this channel at patreon.com
slash old shift X Cheers